[Music]
reading
show refuses to show us the over 18
karate tournament the finishing moves
there are much better
since our friends over at cinemason
somehow haven't seen this yet i guess it
falls on me to point out the important
things
like how huge the pinky finger on that
logo is whose pinky is that much bigger
than their ring finger
[Applause]
yep that's what it's all about
encouraging our youth to continue
competing even when risking further
injury
seems like a worthy cause where do i
send my check
this freeze frame style combined with
lawrence's hair animes so hard they
might as well have included the swing
from naruto
hecklers cool it's one of those present
day shows where the time setting of the
show changes based on when i watch it
can't wait to watch it in 2067 and
wonder why no one has self-flying cars
yet unless it's actually present day
meaning christmas
wait is it christmas also we all know
eating chips in bed is like one of the
sinniest sins to ever sin and it's
sin-filled sin pants
but we also know that this is
intentional character work that the show
is doing
but we also also know that if you leave
chips in your bed at night they wouldn't
stay this tidily staged by the back
as if there ever were any doubt this
results in a sin we know character has a
drinking problem because open bottles of
alcohol are randomly spread throughout
the living space cliche
hey i'm
to see that available kids good to see
pixar's coco is still being promoted in
whatever present day year you're
watching this also stopping in the
absolute center of the crosswalk
we get it zapk is an [ __ ] now you're
just piling on show
gotta be kidding me i have another one
is this really something johnny is
perturbed by or jealous of
i would think seeing someone promote
themselves based on a karate tournament
they won 30-plus years prior would just
be hilarious and sad
being surprised this approach doesn't
work not bad enough you took
my powder room calling your bathroom the
powder room oh no no no no i didn't call
her a [ __ ] i said she was bitching at
me
there's a difference semantics also just
happening to park at a scenic overlook
for your phone conversation is such a
very tv thing to do it's almost a cliche
also also i get this is kind of the
point but they're beating me over the
head with this
not only does johnny lose at karate
tournaments he also loses at life things
so much i now have a migraine
now excuse me while i go to the powder
room to see if i have any more sodium
bicarbonate tablets i was given them at
the apothecary
bonsai i'm daniel larusso
convenient radio ad that not only just
happens to be playing but is also at the
exact start of the ad
is convenient aren't you gonna wear
gloves you're getting pizza at a gas
station man the cash you're holding it
cloth-free is the least of your problems
what do you got hector oh someone has
freaking diarrhea
these bullies are so unimaginative and
terrible stephen king wouldn't even
write him into a book
hey we should call him maria that's
gastroenteritis
he's still eating that pizza that was a
four biter at most
standing still for your pepto shower why
wouldn't you move your choice here
is completely abysmal hey where you
going
this is a perfect example of how this
show builds empathy and depth for johnny
while maintaining his [ __ ] status he
doesn't defend miguel
he defends his own car it's an authentic
character choice and doesn't
short-circuit any of the character work
that's been done
some of that's in zapk's performance
some of it's in the writing but
either way i'm gonna have to take off a
sin i'm not saying these kids don't
deserve an ass beating but they're still
kids and johnny is very much an adult at
least
legally we are supposed to be rooting
for him right are we supposed to assume
that's johnny's pizza she's eating
because there is now a lot more left
than he had a second ago
apparently even paper thin bully
stereotypes can suffer from a severe
case of one at a time itis
this matter having trouble breathing
call backs
actually this is going to happen a lot
like a lot a lot so let's just go with
five sins and then i can secretly enjoy
the nostalgia porn without feeling as
guilty
all right you want my advice stop being
so annoying maybe you'll
stop getting your ass kicked the advice
my big brother of america gave me as a
kid somehow makes its way into this
episode his name was carl
which i would like to point out for no
particular reason is still a better name
than grogu
you got encore who asks if you have
encore the only middle of the day
programming on encore would either be
one of those bad star trek sequels or
godzilla and i mean the terrible
godzilla that the white house down guy
directed with ferris bueller and the
artist who formerly voiced a poo
rc cola chappie
also tv isn't a signo there that's
better
also also show reminds me of the iron
eagle and chappie movies at the same
time
all you need to blast your way in and
get back what they took from you
bonsai that's where you decide to cut to
commercial no one even said the name of
the show
and as always every customer leaves
with their very own bonsai tree how is
this gift even an incentive
not only am i giving you a healthy
portion of my income for your product
but
now you're giving me something i'm gonna
have to take care of or it'll die you
might as well be giving away fish or
puppies or recently graduated philosophy
majors
also does that mean every dealership has
to have their own bonsai garden or
greenhouse
that's a lot of unnecessary
we kicked overhead competition i get
that you broke the screen but
why does the sound feel like you just
stretched out an old cassette we
kicked the competition why would the
sound distort like that because you
broke a tv screen
two minutes of montage style recapping
of the entire plot of the karate kid
look movie if i wanted to watch a movie
in fragments with absolutely no context
i just watched the sins video
also having a flashback to something you
didn't witness also also
having more flashback montages than
rocky iv
there are no airbag sensors on your
steering wheel hey where do i pick it up
it's on the card first most tow services
will ask you where
you want it towed not just take it
somewhere and make you go there
second just answer the man you know
where it's going so what's with the
guessing games it's almost like your
obfuscation is an attempt to have a big
reveal mo
there it is it's gonna be at least a
couple weeks but we'll call you with an
estimate no no no my car was not
supposed to come here
okay i want to do a different body shop
why
maybe because he's the customer do they
not teach customer service at larusso
auto or are they too busy with the
forced narrative tension classes
before you go mr larusso wanted to thank
you personally
and of course daniel is here at this
exact moment even though his dealership
has multiple locations
because reasons does he do this with
every customer how would he do this with
every customer
how the hell are you hugging your old
high school rival without explicit
consent
it was an illegal kick oh illegal really
come on what about that elbow to my knee
yeah i got a warning you got the win
rick from hot tub time machine would be
excellent at cinemasins on
tv since hey dad look loose
[Music]
and of course danny boy's girl was in
the car that hit his but
at least the show won't turn into a
series of coincidental relationships
interactions and misunderstandings to
keep building tension through love
triangles mentor triangles and parenting
triangles
season after season after season and
that will never happen
littering i'm gonna teach you how to
awaken the snake within you
kama sutra classes
i hope that both of you have sons
handsome beautiful
articulate sons who are talented and
star athletes
and they have their legs taken away free
pillow patties
let's take a winston break have a
glorious commercial
he likes it you can taste
you wanted hair it's more
[Music]
[Music]
commercials
[Music]
[Music]
tired
gonna wear gloves you're gonna pay now
you're gonna pay on layaway
the boogeyman is coming leave me alone
you're nothing you're lost you're a
loser
every customer gets one i have no tree
waiting for me